European commission's press storm this
is the press conference following the
college to college meeting between the
European commission and the African
Union commission president Wonderland
and chairperson musafaki will deliver
introductory statements after which we
will take a few questions
thank you very much good afternoon or
good evening to all of you
Mr chairperson what a pleasure to have
you here
and thank you very much for to you and
your Commissioners for very productive
meeting this afternoon it was a very
timely moment to meet because the
current geopolitical context requires us
to work more closely together
we remember just that just after a few
days after EU Africa Summit in February
Russia started to warn European soil
with massive consequences globally and
in these turbulent times the African
Europe partnership is more important
than ever
today's meeting confirmed that we all
remain strongly committed to this
partnership and that we are ready to
work even closer together to address the
impacts of Russia's warrant to deliver
on our joint perspectives I want to
highlight three topics among many that
have been discussed today the first is
food security
Russia's world has a devastating impact
on food security and this affects every
region of the world and mostly also
Africa very directly
we're taking many steps to alleviate the
impact
we're helping to bring in out of Ukraine
to the global market for that we have
established in April the priority routes
via Railroad and rivers we call them the
solidarity Lanes
more than 17 million tons of Ukrainian
agricultural products have been exported
so far through these solidarity Lanes
we welcome
um that on top comes the export through
the UN grain deal
and therefore we are as European Union
ready to mobilize more than 4.5 billion
euros only for Africa till 2024. not
only to give immediate food assistance
that is important now but also to work
on improving and increasing local food
production with modern Technologies
so we're working on that was very
interesting to listen to The Working
session today in this college to college
meeting together with our African
Partners to make the Food Systems more
resilient
and more self-sufficient
I think there is an enormous potential
listening to The Experts to scale up the
food production in Africa and mostly to
have more processing on the continent so
that there is value added to the product
from cashew to cacao there are many
examples where this should be possible
um and of course a second important
topic in the food security element is
that we are investing in Innovative
agricultural processes like for example
the next generation of fertilizers
so we want to work together on Solutions
here to make fertilizers in Africa not
only accessible but also affordable
there are many topics that we touched on
in the field of the fertilizers
bottlenecks where you have to work on
problems that we solved and with that
experience that it's not very not
one-dimensional but multi-dimensional we
agreed today to launch a Joint Task
Force on fertilizers to tackle together
the various challenges for the short and
for the long term what fertilizers are
concerned
second big topic is of course the energy
crisis
Russia's blackmail with energy was an
eye-opener for us the European Union
and we are not only diversifying our
energy
to the energy demand to Reliable
suppliers but we are massively
accelerating the clean energy transition
and I think this is a defining moment
where we can join forces
Africa has abundant resources for clean
energy
and the shift to clean energy if we do
it right could provide access for
Africans to clean energy that is
homegrown and that is Affordable
this needs investment and you can count
on our support to make this happen
we are already mobilizing massive
funding for energy projects from solar
to hydropower to interconnectors
but in addition to that
I think this energy transition might
bring new economic opportunities to
Africa because the world needs renewable
energy and Africa could become a major
exporter of renewable energy to the
world
we have already together taken the very
first steps by assigning renewable
energy Partnerships for example with
Namibia for example with Egypt in the
margins of cop 27 and more will follow
thirdly we discussed about the
implementation of our joint priorities
we have already a common agenda which we
agreed last February at The aueu Summit
and we have a tool to implement it that
is our global gateway investment plan
for Africa worth 150 billion euros
and here it is our common approach to
define the mature projects that are
important
we are partially already delivering with
decisive infrastructure infrastructure
projects I have already mentioned the
energy projects everyone knows our
vaccine projects the vaccine projects
are very impressive because they show
exemplary what we have to combine in
such Investments it's public money it's
private money technology has to go to
the continent and skills have to be
developed locally this is so important
of course there's also the very
important topic of Transport we've
recently inaugurated a highway along the
northern Corridor and Kenya
um and work should start soon on
submarine cables to digitally connect
eastern and western Africa with Europe
so these are many different examples but
um they show the direction of travel
for these projects we are ready to sign
a new financing agreement with 750
million euros on clean energy on
strategic transport corridors and on
digitalization
my final takeaway from our afternoon
dear Musa is that we are delivering on
our agenda despite the turbulent
geopolitical situation we see and I
think we can achieve even more because
we share many objectives for example the
necessary reforms in WTO and the UN
system or the debt relief for vulnerable
countries you have our full support
of course the necessity to fight climate
change
and this is a reason why I fully support
Africa's ambition to play a stronger
role in the multilateral system
including the G20
and at the cop conference for the
climate so you're right
um to insist on that
it is good that the cop 27s took a step
towards climate Justice with loss and
damage
and you can count on the European Union
to help make it operational
and of course in that context we expect
all major emitters to contribute to loss
and damage and climate adaptation
we will keep on working on this and many
more projects and I'm very much looking
forward to take stock the next time when
we are visiting this college is visiting
your college in Addis abiba thank you
very much
[Music]
foreign
continue
the new deliberation
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
ER
locations
[Music]
important
terrorism is Mozambique
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Continental
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
purity
is I say see some million Africa some
prevent electricity
a donkey
in the necessity
transition energetic business
foreign
[Music]
energy
the security Elementor
Treasures
that is
[Music]
[Music]
Ukraine
mathematic
pose an African beautiful here and
ground problem
s
is
foreign
foreign
[Music]
travel
[Music]
hello problematicism
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
merci beaucoup we will now take a few
questions of course we have the
journalists present in the room but just
for Mr chairperson to no we also have
Johnny's connected remotely so I will
also give the photo to some of those if
they wish to take the floor so yes
please go ahead
very much and thank you for having this
chance to exchange on this this topic
after February uh my name is Vince
Chadwick I'm a journalist with devex in
Brussels
um I wanted to ask a question to um
president wonderlaim so much of the
European commission's political energy
goes into the EU Au relationship and we
see that today but it's another African
presence in Brussels called the oacps
the organization of African Caribbean
Pacific States who uh have just lost one
of their biggest members in South Africa
and EU taxpayers pay millions of dollars
to this organization every year but
whenever Europe talks to Africa it's
often with the Au and I wondered what
your explanation and justification is to
your European citizens who are
contributing to the eu's relationship
with the ACP when even South Africa is
now leaving the ACP and the signature of
the post College New agreement is stuck
for various reasons notably being
blocked by Hungary
is it time now to turn the page
on the post-continue agreement to not
sign it to move on and to come up with a
new way to relate to the Pacific and the
Caribbean and to find this forum is the
home for a logical measured accountable
transparent relationship with Africa so
what's the point of the post-continue
agreement today it's basically my
question and to chairperson faki I
wanted to
ask you you said um
that the relationship with Europe is
going well
um obviously it's a short period of time
February to November
what concrete deliverables can you point
to that you welcome that have happened
since February in the summit and and now
what what's going well and what's not
going well in your view thank you
so I think it's always worse to invest
um strength and time into relationships
that have been established whether they
go through difficult times or whether we
are in good times and of course beyond
that we do have also other bilateral
relationship to the pacifics and the
Caribbean so topics where we're working
together are also on the agenda so I
would not want to give up on that
Africa
and please
don't foreign
security
system
[Music]
for example
for example on so many
uh the finance
principle the another mission
transformation
it is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Mercy
[Music]
result
insisted
necessities
engagement
is
a dynamic presence is
the next question will be for Rosie also
connected remotely
let's see if it works
hello
hi Rosie we can see you we can hear you
go ahead fantastic thank you very much
Rosie burchard for feature story news
I'm reporting for sabc news in South
Africa I have a question first of all
for Mr faki so on uh the global gateway
initiative certainly some people here in
Brussels say it's unclear what this is
really delivering in your point of view
since the summit has there been enough
concrete deliverables and just quickly
EU development ministers also met today
there are some fears that funds
may be diverted toward Ukraine away from
priorities on the African continent they
use high representative us at Braille
says no Euro allocated for Africa will
be sent to Ukraine but for example with
the European peace facility we see a lot
of funds going toward Ukraine are you
concerned about these two priorities
that you use juggling and to president
vonderlein do you think there's
sufficient room in the EU budget to
cater to these different priorities in
Ukraine but also commitments and
Ambitions on the African continent thank
you very much
institutions
[Music]
[Music]
yes absolutely I can confirm that
um so global gateway is delivering and
it's very clear the 150 billion euros
that are assigned for global gateway
Africa our fresh money and are assigned
only
um for global gateway Africa
um and you can see the deliverable for
example in the vaccine Story I mean just
a year ago there was nothing but now we
have with four different regions uh
under global gateway the project of
vaccine manufacturing development
uh capabilities that have to be
developed
we make clear sure that the MRNA
technology which is the life-saving
technology for the vaccines
is coming to the continent
we are providing public money as I said
private money has to come too we're
working very closely together to create
the conducive regulatory environment
with the African medicines Agency for
example and of course the main goal is
to have this vaccine manufacturing
capacities working to bring skills to
the region so to have the skilled
personnel and that is the difference of
global gateway com compared to others
who come with infrastructure projects
there's transparency there's good
governance there is the absolute goal to
have locally an added value in skills in
manufacturing capacity that is produced
there or for example transport corridors
that are established so that it brings
work to the region and high quality
um we have different
strategic topics where we are investing
in I mentioned already the health topic
of course the connectivity the transport
routes but also the digital connectivity
plays an enormous role of course energy
and here renewable energy plays a role I
mentioned the hydrogen Partnerships that
we have signed which will then be
implemented in projects and investment
for producing hydrogen just to name a
few I think it is worth to look at the
fact sheets that we are publishing where
all the different projects are are
summarized and this shows the width of
the investment but also shows the
Strategic direction of travel
thank you very much indeed factions were
also a joint price statement have been
published as we were speaking here I see
no further questions at this stage so
thank you very much uh to the president
and to Mr chairperson and have a good
evening
thank you